in the city of Zhengzhou frustration
boiled over into Fury
workers at Apple's biggest assembly
plant their expression of anger met with
this
there's been a covert outbreak here many
unable to leave the factory compound
they say there's insufficient food and
now delays to promised payments some it
seems have had enough
but across China the virus is surging
and there's a sense things are shifting
in central Beijing business after
business bolted shut the authorities
here won't use the word but this city is
now essentially in lockdown there's a
weary acceptance from many but a heavy
price too paid for by people by cafes
like Mr zhongs
foreign
there had been hope that all this might
start to ease off the government had
called for a less blanket approach more
targeting fewer tests but that's
faltered in the face of surging
infections while local authorities have
been instructed to try and ease covert
measures it seems they've not been
instructed to hold their nerve when
cases inevitably rise so Under Pressure
they've done what they've always done
which is to close things down it
illustrates the fundamental trap of
China's zero covert agenda there is no
way out of it without Rising infections
and deaths and the government have spent
three years telling people that that is
unacceptable
okay I arrived to the door and people
are angry zhongmong filmed this video
for us from his home in Chongqing
you can't leave the pandemic worker
tells him this compound is high risk
it's rare for people here to challenge
things so plainly but he's clear China
is getting this wrong the word cap
mimics the government of our Emperors
because everybody at home still watching
the TV and a there's no mask
why Chinese is different from the rest
of the world because our body condition
is weaker or the only grow in China is
stronger there's supposed to be a
reasonable reason there's no reason at
all they just force us stay at home
there are lots of people here who
support xero covered many are afraid of
the virus it's another major obstacle
for a regime that in the coming weeks
will face many Helena Smith Sky News in
Beijing